[Music]
minecraft is huge with more than 100
million players 19 million PC downloads
and 54 million units sold
minecraft is one of the biggest video
games on the planet but those numbers
are just the start
in 2011 minecraft a 241 million logins
per month in 2014 Microsoft bought the
game for 2.5 billion dollars and today
those players have played more than 2
billion hours on the Xbox 360 alone in a
24 hour span the game has had as many as
16 thousand downloads and 350,000
dollars of in-game purchases in January
of this year developer Nathan Adams
tweeted that more than nine hundred and
ninety-eight thousand people were
playing at once and that was not a peak
play time so how does the game fit all
these Steve's Enderman and cows well
according to several users the entire
Minecraft overworld has enough volume
for one quintillion 48 quadrillion 576
trillion square meter blocks and the
maximum theoretical surface area is 4
billion 96 million square kilometres
which is about 8 times greater than
Earth's and if you wanted to explore all
of it one user calculated that it would
take about three trillion hours or about
4.4 million average human lifespans
another user calculated that the game
can generate 18 quintillion possible
worlds one brave minecraft who named
kurt j mac even decided to try and walk
to the edge of his world so far he has
walked more than nine hundred nineteen
thousand five hundred ninety-two miles
and his current pace it will only take
him another 21 years to get there which
is great because he has already raised
over two hundred sixty nine thousand
dollars with his minecraft charity walks
so beyond incredibly long walks and
running from creepers what do players do
in the world this large build
megastructures of course one user built
the Tower of Babel with over seven
million blocks and 90 thousand lights
another built a track eight miles long
the half hour drive in the Minecraft are
the Danish geo Donna agency even created
the entire country of Denmark on a
one-to-one scale it has four trillion
blocks takes up a terabyte of data and
is one of Minecrafts 12 World Records of
course if you want to know just how big
minecraft really is all you have to know
is that in 2014
minecraft was a number to search term
for all of YouTube beating out Beyonce
Taylor Swift and
Rosen like we said minecraft is huge oh
and don't forget to check out more
episodes of data attack and subscribe to
the wired Channel